if you follow 800 of the top people and
you watch all their stories and you
watch it for a month inevitably of that
800 137 of them will put out some sort
of reference or show you that they're
playing videos
you got your prospective happy don't you
want to be happy
[Music]
everyone this is Aaron axis Lyman from
generating sports and I'm gonna have to
explain the man they are Gary Vaynerchuk
you are here at the first call to be
home stand
and obviously rockers the one yesterday
how is it the see that first win and the
first match the season you know I've
I've never been in the position I was in
last night which is I've been such a
hardcore sports fan my whole life but to
actually be an owner and I was wildly
nervous yeah you know I I actually liked
before the match started I was like man
I wish we didn't have the first home
stand because because I don't mind
losing I really don't I
it's a process but with all the build-up
and your home to like lose your home
opener and the gooery listen I'm in a
space now the gorillas had a lot of like
I think I think they have a good
organization but if there's definitely
been a lot of chatter and social like
they're disorganized you're not
practicing enough like and then they get
off to that hot start and I'm like okay
this is really bad you know I love
boxing
yeah and I'm always affected by when the
kid goes back to their hometown and lose
the fight in the hometown it's like this
moment in boxing that I think a lot
about and so when it was when we were
down to Oh before they got disqualified
I made it 1-1 I was like I don't know if
we can curse on cheddar but I was like
son of a gun we're gonna be that boxer
that loses in their hometown so how does
it feel to be frank and transparent I'll
relief exciting but way more importantly
that that's just my competitive DNA in
the macro like the fact that I'm gonna
watch this video of you and I 39 years
from now and be like my god look at the
humble beginnings of this league that
now is selling a hundred fifty thousand
to ckets in a minute to the world and
the championship match I already know
that's been written histories always be
written so it is two that we found out
yesterday about the partnership deal
with Google and YouTube and this was
kind of like a shocker to many of the
gamers because obviously twitch is the
leading show
platform right now and now we're
starting to see the lights are like
Facebook gaming and YouTube and even mix
are coming into the whole streaming
battles and as someone who has
capitalized in an elevated terms of
content on YouTube how do you see this
partnership kind of elevating on the
Call of Duty League but then also I
guess YouTube as a platform competing
with the likes of like a twitch I think
it's a great question um you know
obviously with overwatch and and other
you know ninja as a personality I think
for the hardcore gaming community no
question twitch and I'm an enormous
twitch fan is an incredible platform and
it was obviously very much in the mix as
the as the home for the screaming you
know to me if you're paying attention
even a little bit I'm sure for you I
mean you're setting up the broad
question to the audience but it wasn't a
shock like if you just if you're even a
little in those are probably the two
places you would have guessed it could
have ended up on right so you know how
do I think about it I think if you're
the hardest core and you've grown up in
the last five to seven years in eSports
there's probably a little bit of part of
you that's saying like oh it should be
on Twitch if you're an entrepreneur and
you're in it you're saying yourself okay
YouTube is so broad it if it's making
this real investment it's going to do
things that broadens the audience there
are going to be millions of people who
have no idea what Call of Duty eSports
for any of this is that are gonna
stumble on this content on YouTube and
next year that is gonna build awareness
my intuition I was not involved in any
of the negotiations I myself you found
out as soon as I did I knew what was
going on but I'm speaking like a social
commentator I always go with broad you
know even when I do my stuff I'm always
thinking broad the first time I ever
decided to do a television show it was
for apples show with you know play the
apps even though it stayed within Apple
music it was Apple the potential for
global broad was there I always go broad
especially when something's new the
exposure matters
twitches is like the spa
gamers know how to find that Karen in
Iowa or Alberta or Shanghai probably not
Carol there is gonna stumble on this
platform through YouTube more likely
than twitch at this point not to
undermine what I think twitch can and
will be common to be very frank
I expect the Netflix's and who lose and
me warner media's and if you are an
entertainment media conglomerate and you
are not paying attention to esports
screaming you are making a humongous
mistake and so you know I was there in
Silicon Valley I was there I'm going
through in sports cards I'm very
touching about sports cards right now
the OGIS of anything even though I was
more og than those oh jeez and sports
cards cuz I did as a kid they're always
scared like a noob and you know how you
follow a band and then they get big and
you get now because they sold out no
they're just going through the
progression I think I think what you'll
see is the hardest core fans of this
sport will realize how good of a deal
this is because it's gonna rise
everything and make it better in a lot
of ways while I know if you're a hippie
or in the streets you're always mad at
anything that scales up but I'm how do I
think it's gonna impact it I think it's
gonna make more eSports fans which I
think will trickle down to impact
everybody in a positive way period in a
story yeah yeah YouTube in terms of its
gaming interface it's not quite
appealing toward certain gamers yet but
it's an easier to user interface for the
Karan's of the world the Josh is the
kind of cut stumble upon the content ,
it's a technology company that can build
the technology you know that will make
it the best for the hardcore gamers and
let toggling happen between slaughter
pants sixty-three and Sally pants 1964
aka the hardcore fan could get what they
want the broad market can get what they
want and and I think that's exactly
right
what what what it needs to do to make
the experience better for the hardcore
gamers a lot easier than it is for
twitch to have a trillion people on the
platform tomorrow
yes indeed so let's talk about growth
overall right obviously eSports is
growing
I've watched videos of you talking about
the investment specifically why you
invested within rocker and the Call of
Duty Pro League versus other leagues
right in terms of just you're someone
who doesn't get into something unless
you're really into it you're really
researching etc from from an investment
standpoint the financial evaluation of
eSports in terms of return on investment
isn't quite there yet right right um
when do you feel like it will get to a
certain point in terms of its trajectory
to the point where like you may see
value as well not necessarily value but
you may be able to get enough profit in
return or you can then go buy the Jets
do you see that it will get to the point
where the financial evaluation from
eSports leagues or teams will actually
exceed those of like the NBA and a
Fallon etc I think there's a potential
that may happen now I think there's
fragmentation in these sports that we
don't see in the NBA like basketballs
humongous but there's one NBA American
football is humongous but there's one
baseball is humongous but there's one
MLB eSports as a whole like those video
game playing competitively is actually
gonna be bigger than all three of those
things may be combined but there may be
39 titles and leagues that play out
which then may create the fact that they
can never get to the value of those
leagues it's all going to be on
supplying the man the reason the NBA and
the NFL and the MLB are where they're at
is because of the TV rights trickling
down the streaming rights have to get to
such a number that that could happen and
so I can tell you this I would be on the
ground shocked and I can't wait to play
these videos in 20 years and say that I
was wrong if these franchises are not
valued far greater than they are right
now this is a game of do you understand
which game is gonna be zelda and Super
Mario versus which game is gonna be Kid
Icarus
right or even Mega Man aka for videogame
people I had to decide that I thought
that Call of Duty would be a game that
people would play 21 years from now
versus what happened to do got it that's
the bet nine eleven twelve thirteen
years ago I do was fortnight doom was
Call of Duty doom was League of Legends
overwatch dooms not winning right now if
Call of Duty isn't one of the biggest
games in 16 years this investment will
lose if it is an evergreen game like a
Zelda you know like I keep using that
because Nintendo helps like there's been
titles that always transfer when I was a
kid Kid Icarus was his biggest burial
for that six months that's the game I
keep playing
is it Mario is a connect us the decision
I went into call duty is I've decided
it's Mario I win big if I'm right
I lose big if I'm if it's connect with
well in addition to the fragmentation to
I think the one thing that we're seeing
in eSports as well is that obviously
they have their hardcore fan base
but it's the segmenting audiences and
still appealing to your heart hardcore
fans well bring in new new fans in the
sense like for example they went over
yesterday in the first matches they went
over the rules when it comes to
hardpoint and etc on the stream you saw
certain individuals who are hardcore
fans they're like why are you showing us
this we already know and so there are
various competitive season okay this
you'll appreciate this that is such a
non-event I'll explain why to your point
there needs to be we have such great
technology it's not television you know
1984 that would have been the case yeah
we as a league the platforms as
platforms have to realize let's create
an AV telecast let's create I mean I
feel the same way about American
football I really know football so when
they're going through it's my Tony Romo
is exploding on the scene to everybody
he's going deeper yeah and there's like
how does he know but I need that stuff
cuz I watch a lot of football but like
when my dad got into it 15 years ago
like this is a pun
and so to the hardcore fans there right
we need I think we should argue that we
should have a hardcore and a casual
broadcast and the hardcore fans should
not see here two rules the hardcore fans
should get into the subtleties of the
skit why the skin is going to come out
tomorrow or thee or the patch that came
out or the backstory of a new player or
the historic you mentary on Hector
going from optic to you know Huntsman
like yeah with you and I think
technology lets us do that whereas
television did not I also think that
part of that too is the the cultural
component as well for example right
every like I love ninja and I love that
he's building his platform I he made a
comment about Drake as an artist making
gaming cool he's definitely helped make
it cool now but I also think there's
this historical and cultural component
to it where you know the lights of the
wu-tang clan and Def Jam fight from New
York and that whole series and even
people like Lupe Fiasco that was very
much involved in the scene and I feel
like there is a close here you're just
awesome you're being really smart right
now I'm sorry to interrupt you but be
sure what you're saying you're right I
mean like I will never forget when I I
don't remember who it was but like to
your point in 2003 or four I saw a
top-15 rapper wear like a Super Mario
hoodie and that was like I was like what
you know to your point you know you know
yeah I mean when you think about Mortal
Kombat looting like things of that
nature
yes I think you're right and and I think
for ninja he's such a young kid tell
there's such a young kid you know look
that was such a moment it was it will
always be a moment and I'm and it's
really it was I mean it was the month I
had been watching the spamming when
justin.tv became twitch I was paying
attention uh and was like okay like you
know but no question I when Ashton
Kutcher joined Twitter and said he would
race CNN to a million followers I had
been on Twitter for years it was what I
talked about Twitter has made it when
when you know dj khaled had his moment
the water fake the jetski thank you d
rock on snapchat that was the next hour
or day when I made my first content of
snapchats here now even though I've been
paying attention for 18 months heavily
when Drake went on that stream the next
day I made my piece of content saying
like eSports is in a different place now
four nights in a different place that
ninjas in a different place now even
though I've been watching that space for
a long time I think that's right but to
your point it's always been there in
different ways so how does how is it
that we can kind of convey that message
or add that culture component in the
historical component cuz there's a lot
of kids that don't they see ninja and
they know ninja but they don't know some
of the back stories of some of this I
think all right I like where you're
going I think that plays out okay you
know like this videos gonna run and
people are gonna lead comments of like
well what about when this person
mentioned Mike Tyson's punch-out in 1998
in 1988 excuse me in hip-hop and then
some kids gonna read that be like oh
this really has been around that long
yeah you understand I think a lot of
times when one's passionate about
something they get anxious to make sure
people know and I always tell people the
truth wins you just got to give it time
to breathe yeah definitely I mean that's
something I've been trying to do is
integrating that culture component and
bring artists on to shatter eSports that
are passionate about this you know they
don't even know I mean you know this
like if you go and follow 700 people
that are cool let's just use the word
culture or cool like whether it's
hip-hop whether it's athletes whether
it's EDM let's go different spaces
whether it's skateboarding surfers that
look very different than the Southside
Atlanta hip hop artists but like play
them all out if you follow 800 of the
top people people that are let's just
use Instagram as the current
establishment that are crushing on that
including women like Emma Chamberlain or
things that nature if you follow all
that and you watch all their stories and
you watch it for a month inevitably of
that 800 137 of them will put out some
sort of reference or show you that
they're playing videos so it's it's
already happened
yeah it's a little happens like I can't
wait for home stands next year because
this year things were rushed as they
should be in a new league our screaming
deal just got done yeah
the league is getting used to it US team
owners are getting used to it we're
gonna have our stuff together for next
year and I promise you next year's home
stands are gonna have 50 to 500 people
in the world pack these events and
people gonna know cuz it already
happened yeah I mean also you know with
the new homestand concept that's
something that is new especially even
for eSports and we're seeing how
traditional sports is kind of bringing
some structure and formatting into the
scene I kinda wanna make a little bit of
a switch please you're very big on tick
tock tick tock obviously with the news
that they're gonna be getting into
gaming with their game studio what are
your thoughts on that smart it's culture
and culture right tick tock has the
attention of an enormous amount of eight
to twenty eight year olds right now I'm
not in Minnesota wearing this rocker
where's my sweater for my health no this
is this is a unbelievable pillar of
culture to the day I guy
and so I I do that as rising both boats
will be good for you Sports will be good
for tick-tock simple enough so bloom off
and then in addition to that you know
with your investments in the call Dooley
are you also potentially looking at
mobile gaming because I know an
interview you're saying especially when
it comes to the demographic in the u.s.
you own it you're learning more about
China and some of the other markets
overseas mobile gaming is something
that's massive over especially in South
Korea and China where and yeah so ah but
you know it's something that's starting
to grow and blossom here in the United
States on it and is quite large to begin
with yeah like when you start throwing
in certain games into the mix I mean the
numbers are staggering in the US yeah I
mean look this is just this is how I
roll
it's all of this is oxygen to me my
oxygen as a human is I want to know what
people are doing and then sometimes I
get in
because it's noble and important to me
sometimes I get involved as a consumer
of it but because of my DNA an enormous
amount of times I get involved as an
entrepreneur because I enjoy it I enjoy
the sport of business and so of course
especially when you look at the female
demographics when you look at the lack
of barrier of entry into it I look at it
all timing I spent an uncomfortable
amount of time paying attention to candy
crush to Angry Birds I analyzed hundreds
now that's not there tens of hours of
what people were doing not watching
people play it watching what people are
saying about it why did they like
farmville right if you go read my book
the Thank You economy in 2010 I talked
about virtual currency that people will
spend real-life money on things that are
digital in essence I mean the amount of
money kids are spending on 2k and Madam
packs skins like it happened it was
obvious to because I already not cuz I'm
a genius because people are already a
little bit doing it for power-ups then
yeah of course I'm watching I'm always
watching of course you are all more so
the last question I actually is more of
an advice thing I'm gonna ask ok so as
someone who is obviously doing
broadcasting the eSports and gaming for
me be in the scene there's already
experts it's already casting some
commentators and one of the things that
I've been kind of paving for myself is
the intersection of eSports gaming and
culture well and that's something that
like what I'm passionate about I'm gonna
used to work in music media I used to
work in traditional sports and so for me
it's been kind of an interesting journey
it's a long journey and I know it's
challenging just because of what we
talked about where it's like the
segmentation we're like that's called do
that you're so super Call of Duty or
they're super overwatch but in terms of
those cultural conversations whether it
is a diversity inclusion orbits whether
hip-hop and etc that stuff is actually
taking time in terms of people being
interested in content do you feel you
know to me just as a question back to us
we're jamming I feel that Call of Duty
is far more cultured oriented than over
what do you think like I see far more
NBA players football players artists
putting out their Call of Duty kind of
content than overwatch yes I do see that
I think that the overwatch like for that
specific game in title they have a
little bit of there's this kind of like
a struggle that they have in the sense
that they are a league that's pretty
much established in United States but
they also have a lot of players are from
overseas yes
and there's that marketing disconnect
specially from your visualization right
but even with the conversations of like
culture I think for me is like the one
thing I've been trying to figure out in
the sense is how do I and I've been
following your method in terms of just
putting it out but I'm really also just
trying to figure out how to go about it
here's how I'd go about it
authenticity reversed create the visual
what do I mean by that
authenticity reverse create the visual
instead of trying to build bring Call of
Duty to the baby watch if magnus
stallion likes Call of Duty got it map
it all of it very much the same for me
like I will never reach out to anybody
nor be receptive if they aren't
interested in entrepreneurship but if
they are then I'm in now what's great
about hip hop as somebody who loves it
is that a lot of them have so much
entrepreneurial DNA athletes too because
the nature of urban life in the streets
leads to entrepreneurial DNA yeah I
would I know joke if we were just like
best friends and doing this together and
being like we care about this yeah I
would spend 800 hours trying to figure
out every single person in the culture
that likes it then reach out to them
then create content around it cuz it's
authentic right it's kind of like wale
with wrestling I love wrestling and I
want more culture wrestling it has to
start with wale cuz he actually loves it
yeah got it I got it I can't go commence
little keyed to come to a wrestling
match with me yeah do you understand
a pit then create the content all right
thank you so much look real pleasure
you